[Musique]
smartphone qu'est-ce que tu regardes les
actus les réseaux sociaux surtout est-ce
que tu regardes le journal télé oui des
fois le soir enfin tous les soirs mais
des fois oui journal papier tu dis quoi
ben ali nouvelle actu l'idée c'est aussi
par exemple les choses olympiques bat
sur l'équipe qui avait tout en direct
c'était oui le sport c'est bien vrai un
fou comment tu t'assures qu'est ce que
tu vois c'est bah c'est vrai parce que
souvent il ya des photos qu'ils le
prouvent faille peut avoir des photos
truquées mais on le voit souvent quand
ces défis et il ya des choses c'est
improbable et du coup on sait
différencier le vrai du faux
qu'est ce que tu penses du métier de
journaliste je pense que c'est bien
parce que on est souvent l écoute avec
des citoyens qui n'importe quel citoyen